nous vous avons proposé de venir ce
matin dans le cadre du projet de loi
constitutionnelle qui est le sénat est
saisie et la modification de son article
premier vrai peut-être vous présenter
madame mélanie blancheteau vous même
monsieur victor costa si vous monsieur
et monsieur grégoire frati seo je
rappelle peut-être pour chacun des
collègues quelques quelques éléments la
création de la convention citoyenne pour
le climat résulte en réalité d'une
initiative du président de la république
qui a annoncé le 25 avril 2019 au
lendemain du grand débat national
lui-même organisé en réponse à la crise
du gilet jaune
c'est la première fois en fait qui était
impliqué et qui était expérimenté en
france et à l'échelle nationale cette
forme de démocratie dite participative
qui repose sur la réunion d'assemblée de
citoyens tirés au sort de manière à
assurer leur représentativité au sens
statistique du terme
en l'occurrence la convention a été
investie d'un rôle consultatif sur un
sujet précisément défini sur la lettre
de mission du premier ministre il
s'agissait et je cite de définir les
mesures structurantes pour parvenir dans
un esprit de justice sociale à réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
d'au moins 40% d'ici 2030 par rapport à
1990 ceci conformément aux objectifs
fixés par l'union européenne
l'organisation de la convention a été
confiée au conseil économique social et
environnemental eu un comité de
gouvernance a été mis en place pour
accompagner la convention constitué de
personnalités qualifiées dans les
domaines du climat de la démocratie
participative géant précises et des
questions économiques et sociales ainsi
que des représentants du ministère de la
transition écologique après huit mois de
travaux
la convention adoptée le 21 juin 2020 un
rapport aux termes duquel 149
propositions ont été formulées
il s'agit je le rappelle d'une première
qui entend répondre à la volonté
expérimenté par de nombreux concitoyens
de participer de façon plus directe et
continue à l'élaboration des décisions
les concernant
c'est tout particulièrement le cas dans
un dancing complexe et transversales que
la protection de l'environnement et
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi la charte de
l'environnement
adopté à l'initiative du président
jacques chirac a consacré le droit de
toute personne de participer à
l'élaboration des décisions publiques
ayant une incidence sur l'environnement
toutefois le sujet qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui concerne la traduction dans
notre ordre juridique des propositions
faites par la convention citoyenne pour
tenter ou améliorer tenter d'améliorer
le frac c'est juste la gouvernance de la
transition écologique
à ce propos la convention a formulé
quatre principales recommandations qui
nécessiterait en tout ou partie une
révision de la constitution
je voudrais vous préciser ces quatre
propositions quatre recommandations de
la première elle a proposé je parle de
la convention de modifier le préambule
de la constitution pour y ajouter une
nouvelle règle de conflit entre
principes constitutionnels sous la forme
d'une phrase qui sera rédigé de la
manière suivante la conciliation des
droits libertés et principes qui en
résultent ne saurait compromettre la
préservation de l'environnement
patrimoine commun de l'humanité
la deuxième recommandation c'est la
modification de l'article 1er de la
constitution nous y arrivons pour y
ajouter un alinéa au terme duquel et je
cite la république garantit la
préservation de la biodiversité de
l'environnement et lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
la troisième recommandation que vous
aviez formulées et le contrôle des
politiques environnementales la
convention propose de créer un défenseur
de l'environnement sur l'exemple modèles
qui existent déjà du défenseur des
droits
et enfin la convention rappelle à
réformer le conseil économique social et
environnemental cher à madame jourdain
d'autres sénatrice i qui était
rapporteur du texte en y incluant des
membres tirés au sort
nos renforçant ses compétences
consultative des recommandations vous
avez formulées nous avons souhaité vous
entendre pour
que vous confirmiez tout ça que votre
votre analyse de façon à ce que le sénat
dans sa sagesse habituel aborde le texte
en ayant entendu tout le monde et il
aura naturellement à
se prononcer dans le courant du mois de
mai au début du mois de mai prochain
c'est à dire finalement assez vite voilà
j'ai été sans doute trop long mais je
pense cette présentation était
nécessaire pour que tout à chacun
si tu les choses je vous redis qui si
vous avez une grande partie des membres
de la commission des lois
certains seront visio je voulais déjà
dit et vous allez présent mon collègue
guillaume chevrollier qui est rapporteur
pour avis de la commission développement
durable sur ce texte et qui est comme
moi en charge de vous entendre de vous
écouter je sais pas mais de vous
entendre bien c'est vous monsieur qui
débute et non justement je voulais
justement doit d'aquafadas pour merci de
nous recevoir et ça va tourner autant
dispose pour ce propos liminaire afin
qu'on soit trop long faucon et
physiciens fini avant 20 heures
non plus sérieusement beaucoup plus
sérieusement 11h20 on peut jusqu'à 12h15
c'est bien en honneur voilà donc une
première présentation d un voyage
question exactement d'accord mais si le
sourire voilà c'est moi qui vais
démarrer les hostilités d'hostilité au
sénat et la contradiction mais pas
d'hostilité
donc je me présente un victor costa
j'habite en bourgogne proche de saint
fargeau belle région
et puis je travaille
comme auto entrepreneur de la
désinfection dératisation
donc voilà pour situer un peu les choses
donc j'ai un petit texte
il vaut ce qu'il vaut mais voilà je les
fais comme ça et on y va alors nous
souhaitons mettre en évidence les
relations des équilibres naturels et des
ressources dans la loi je me suis permis
de 32,2 petit passage de du préambule de
la charte de l'environnement parce que
je trouve que c'est plus pertinents
que les articles en fait donc je les
cite le peuple français considérant que
les ressources et les équilibres
naturels en conditionné l'émergence de
l'humanité que l'avenir est l'existence
même de l'humanité sont indissociables
de son milieu naturel qu afin d'assurer
un développement durable les choix
destiné à répondre aux besoins du
présent ne doivent pas compromettre la
capacité des générations futures et des
autres peuples à satisfaire leurs
propres besoins
préambule de la charte de
l'environnement 2005 donc partant de ce
postulat que pourrait t'il advenir si
les ressources viennent à manquer et si
les équilibres sont rompues que peux tu
eu que peu que peut aussi se passer que
peut-il se passer
la question des ressources sont elles un
fini ou infini non spécifiées dans la
charte de l'environnement il semble
raisonnable de penser qu'il ne peut y
avoir de ressource infinie dans un monde
fini
l'objectif de cette proposition est
multiple il faut obliger l'état français
à agir mais aussi lui rappeler son
obligation de résultats tels que son
engagement dans les coop et c'est
l'objectif d'un verbe d'action comme
garantir inclure la notion de climat non
présent dans la charte de
l'environnement réaffirmé la protection
de la biodiversité nécessaires à un
maintien des écosystèmes rendre la
juriprudence plus hypes explicite pour
les législateurs renforcer réaffirmé la
charte de l'environnement par une double
inscription dans la constitution
cette proposition est aussi celle
partagée par est soutenue par de
nombreuses ong constitutionnaliste
parlementaire elle est donc acceptable
par la société comme par les juristes
elle a également la force d'être claires
concises et évite toute interprétation
malhabile
aujourd'hui il existe un projet
gouvernemental pour inscrire
l'environnement dans la constitution qui
se rapproche de notre proposition mais
avec le terme agir néanmoins cette
notion d' agir est juridiquement pas
satisfaisante
le terme agir n'a pas grand sens
juridique alors que garantir à une
connotation plus forte avec obligation
de résultat non ne nous trompons pas il
ne s'agit pas de garantir d'arrêter le
changement climatique mais de garantir
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique
c'est une garantie de moyens et non pas
une garantie de résultats à la finale ça
sera quand même une garantie de
résultats mais bon c'est ce qu'on
souhaite garantir c'est ce que nous
proposons il faut imposer une contrainte
forte pour garantir le respect des
textes actée par la constitution via la
charte de l'environnement et l'article
premier de la constitution la république
française doit protéger l'environnement
et la biodiversité en respect des
générations futures
elles mêmes en charge de perpétuer la
continuité de l'humanité en respect avec
les écosystèmes merci monsieur je vous
précise que le projet de loi tel qu'il a
été déposé
utilise bien le terme de leur garantir
messieurs bien sûr justement j'avais
faire le lien avec sa présentation
rappelons que effectivement ce qui est
des skis étaient soulignées par par
monsieur costa c'est que y avait une
proposition initiale du gouvernement qui
était sur southern agir et justement moi
j'arrivais sur la construction de cette
proposition par les citoyens de la
convention citoyenne présente très
rapidement donc grégoire frati moi je
suis un citoyen normand de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat effectivement
nous on a fait une construction nouvelle
on a repris en fait ce qui était
existant autour de cette modification de
l'article 1 on avait des propositions de
la fondation nicolas hulot
la proposition du gouvernement la
proposition de certains
constitutionnalistes et finalement ce
composé des 150 c'est quelque chose de
nouveau
on n'avait jamais lisse et 17 ou 18 ans
selon surprendre apostrophes
dans ce sens là avec ce terme garantir
avec ce terme la lutte on est allé vers
quelque chose qui répandait un certain
équilibre est finalement bien que j'ai
entendu certaines fois en fait personne
n'est venu nous glisser à l'oreille
cette proposition qui est le fruit d'une
construction citoyenne et moi je tenais
à le rappeler parce que comme vous
l'avez très bien dit tout à l'heure
c'est c'est nouveau c'est la prévention
citoyennes et des citoyens se sont
attachés à réfléchir à l'objet
constitutionnelle et je trouvais ça
intéressant et important de le rappeler
parce que dans le symbole
c'est moi je trouve ça plutôt positif de
voir le citoyen s'intéresse aussi à la
constitution n'est pas simplement aux
lois qui agissent et qui régissent notre
pays
donc oui notre proposition avec ce terme
garantis avec ce terme lille ce sont des
mots forts ce sont des verbes forme et
on en à peser chaque mot
on a rencontré beaucoup d'experts
beaucoup de scientifiques beaucoup de
constitutionnalistes beaucoup de
beaucoup d'élus comme vous le faite vous
également d'ailleurs ou comme l'ont fait
les collections à l'assemblée nationale
et on en arrivait donc à faire ses choix
ses choix de la convention citoyenne en
fais tout moi je le présente comme une
proposition faite assez modérée qui
arrive sur sur un fil
parce qu'en fait nous sommes arrivés
avec des verbes fort comme je les ai
déjà dit plusieurs fois que garantir et
la lutte mais nous avons aussi l'idée de
côté certaines propositions qui nous
était proposé et que nous avons
proposées nous avions trouvé trop
ambitieuse par exemple nous n'avons pas
parlé de limites planétaires ou de
principes de non régression parce que
nous voulions justement arriver à ce
consensus entre nous déjà nous avions eu
du mal à le trouver parce
qu'effectivement nous avions certains
citoyens qui disait attention le genre
de gars en tirer trop fort ou attention
cette proposition n'est pas assez forte
et c'est cet équilibre-là qui arrivait à
faire consensus parmi les 150 et qu'on
n'essaye apporté au consensus politique
maintenant au sein des parlements pour
l'étape d'après bien sûr je le rappelle
arrivé au référendum arriver à ce
consensus au référendum au consensus au
sein de la population
donc oui comme l'a rappelé victoire il y
avait il ya déjà une charte de
l'environnement qui apporte certains
effets mais finalement cette charte de
l'environnement il n'y a pas la notion
de climat
c'est un peu un bloc qui est
difficilement maniable par les
juridictions on a bien vu et c'est
d'ailleurs une partie du constat que
nous avions fait et ce pour quoi nous
pension utile de donner un outil à
juridiques supplémentaires pour
permettre justement à l'environnement la
biodiversité et la lutte contre les
dérèglements climatiques d'avoir quelque
chose de plus fort pour pouvoir les
protéger ma collègue mélanie blanche
tout reviendra sur sur le choix de ses
terres mais sur pourquoi est ce que ces
termes sont choisi judicieusement par
les citoyens si je peux le dire j'ai
juste finir mon propos sur le fait que
outre tous les aspects juridiques
l'aspect démocratique l'aspect
écologique il ya un aspect symbolique je
vous la corde mais pour moi ça ne doit
pas être un contre argument parce que
cet aspect symbolique il important le
drapeau bleu-blanc-rouge la marseillaise
sont des symboles forts qui en fait
anime chaque français nous on veut que
l'écologie puisse animer également
chaque français puisse être un autre de
ses symboles forts on a besoin de
symboles l'article loin donne un peu la
direction de la démocratie française
il nous semblait nous important dit m
d'autant plus par référendum ses notions
là mais bien sûr il ya cette notion de
symbole mais pas que et du coup je vais
passer la main madame blanche tôt pour
vous parler notamment de tous les effets
juridiques également qu on escompte
derrière cette proposition
merci bonjour à tous merci beaucoup de
nous recevoir c'est un honneur donc je
m'appelle mélanie j'ai 37 ans je suis
cadre dans l'événementiel et j'habite
dans les hauts-de-seine et je n'étais
pas afin de l'attirer au sort comme mes
autres concitoyens pas spécialement
militants tout écolo on a vraiment
citoyenne lambda radio
donc donc effectivement comme le disait
grégoire on hésitait avec une
formulation plus ambitieuse mais on
s'est contenté d'une formulation qui
nous paraissait raisonnable est pas
révolutionnaire et de et on a tenu
compte en fait de nombreuses voix qui
qui se ce qui s'élèvent pour dire que si
la république ne garantit pas c'est
juste du greenwashing institutionnels et
par cette cette réforme
et si elle va au référendum ce serait
pour que le peuple précise et réaffirme
sa volonté et les obligations juridiques
de la charte de l'environnement
donc on a d'autres si vous les dents
dans les échanges qu'on aura peut-être
le temps d'avoir après on pourra
échanger sur les les arguments et la
réflexion qu'on a eues mais on
souhaitait partager avec vous une note
de marie-anne cohendet je sais pas si
vous l'avez déjà auditionné donc qui est
professeur de droit à la sorbonne
constitutionnaliste constitutionnaliste
et spécialiste en droit de
l'environnement sur les risques de cette
inscription à l'article 1er est ensuite
les risques d'une non inscription de
cette norme à l'article 1er donc dans
les risques de l'inscription
le premier cité est ce que ce serait un
effet boîte de pandore il existe un
effet boîte de pandore pour n'importe
quel révision constitutionnelle qu'il
s'agisse de l'article 1er ou d'autres
articles par exemple l'article 34 même
s'il est légèrement plus important pour
l'article 1er les revendications qui
peuvent s'exprimer sinon commence à
modifier l'article 1er peuvent être
écartées aisément d'un point de vue
politique notamment en observant qu une
action forte pour protéger
l'environnement et lutter contre les
changements climatiques est revendiquée
depuis longtemps et avec constance par
nono président de la république ce qui
n'est pas le cas d'autres réformes
de plus elle est dictée par l'urgence
deuxième risque de transformer l'article
1er en catalogue certains reprochent à
l'article 1er de devenir une sorte de
catalogue au fil des révisions
successives
c'est normal car cette car cet article
énonce les principes fondamentaux et ses
principes peuvent légitimement être
modifié avec l'évolution des
connaissances par exemple sur les
changements climatiques
c'est une bonne chose que ces principes
puissent être temps de chien au fil du
temps car cela montre que les
représentants du peuple sont allés coûte
de 6 des citoyens et savent faire
évoluer
constitution avec les grands changements
de société troisième risque sur des
risques juridiques les risques
juridiques qui seraient conséquents
david boyd un canadien qui est
rapporteur aux nations-unies sur les
notions humain a étudié les dispositions
constitutionnelles relatives à
l'environnement et leur application par
les pouvoirs publics et par les juges
dans tous les pays du monde il a
constaté que dans tous les pays
l'adoption de ces normes avait été
contesté par des groupes de personnes
qui invoquait toujours les mêmes
arguments pour siaap pour s'y opposer et
que dans tous les cas l'expérience a
prouvé qu'aucune de ces craintes ne
s'est concrétisé par exemple que ces
dispositions n'étaient pas normatif car
trop flou trop imprécises elles ne sont
pas plus que la liberté l'égalité où la
laïcité et de nombreux tribunaux qu'ils
soient constitutionnelles judiciaires ou
administratives administratifs ont
appliqué ces règles exactement comme
d'autres règles constitutionnelles que
ce que ce ne serait pas directement que
ça risquerait de générer des milliers de
procès ici des milliers de qpc donc
question de priorités constitutionnel
plus de contentieux aurait paralysé les
tribunaux au contraire les tribunaux ont
fait preuve d'une prudence souvent
excessive dans l'application de ces
nouvelles normes constitutionnelles
en france nous avons déjà l'expérience
de la charte de l'environnement dont
certains prédisaient au moment de son
élaboration qu'elle conduirait à
l'asphyxié des tribunaux alors que les
juges seront appliquées l'on applique
avec beaucoup de modération que cette
modification conduirait à des atteintes
au libre oies et libertés fondamentaux
cela ne peut pas être le cas car si la
république doit garantir l'action contre
les changements climatiques tout comme
elle garantit par exemple la laïcité ou
l'égalité dans tous les cas ces nouveaux
droits et libertés constitutionnels ont
la même valeur que les autres et donc
les juges et notamment le juge
constitutionnel doivent les garantir
tous en mettant en balance les attentes
porté par les uns pour garantir les
autres ils n'auront pas ils pourront par
exemple constaté que certaines
limitations pourront être apportées au
droit de propriété ou à la liberté
d'entreprendre pour garantir la survie
de la planète mais il verra toujours à
ce que ces limitations soit justifiée et
proportionnée et qu'elle ne porte pas
atteinte à une atteinte excessive aux
autres droits notamment la propriété ou
la liberté d'entreprendre que cela
risquerait de ruiner l'économie en
paralysant les entreprises l'expérience
a prouvé le contraire les expériences
les entreprises ne sont pas pas
alizée ni l'économie ni nulle part au
monde remise en cause par ces normes le
monde des entreprises est un site et de
manière progressive et raisonnable à
développer des activités plus
respectueuse de l'environnement
ces dernières années sous l'influencé
des compagnies d'assurance en
particulier le monde des entreprises a
compris que ce n'est pas la lutte contre
les changements climatiques qui risquait
de l'uriné et bien au contraire des
changements climatiques eux-mêmes et
donc ligne l'inaction contre ces
changements
loin de remettre en cause la survie de
l'économie ces normes peuvent elles
peuvent au contraire l'assuré
durablement pour bien établir le bilan
coût avantage de cette inscription à
l'article 1er on peut donc réfléchir aux
risques liés à l'absence de cette
inscription
donc je vais vous les citer il ya six
points et je vais terminer donc ce sera
le premier point la script sion à
l'article 34 a pour seule conséquence de
restreindre au parlement le pouvoir
donc si par exemple on inscrivait à
l'article 34 et par l'article le premier
comme ça avait été proposée donc ça
aurait pour seule conséquence de
restreindre par de restreindre parlement
le pouvoir de définir les principes de
l'action dans ce domaine deuxième point
risque de désillusions d'impression
d'avoir été floués par des discours
politiques ambitieux troisième point
l'obligation de lutter contre ces
changements ne serait pas imposé par la
constitution et cette action dépendrait
donc du parlement et non pas de la
volonté du peuple inscrit dans la
constitution par ses représentants
quatrième point l'obligation d'agir
contre ces changements climatiques
pourrait être remise en cause au premier
changement de majorité
puisqu'elle serait dictée par la loi et
non pas par la constitution cinquième
point l'accord de paris pourraient être
dénoncés a à l'occasion d'un tel
changement
et enfin dernier point la france serait
moins avancés que d'autres pays alors
qu'elle entend être leader mondial dans
ce domaine
alors que ça c'était une note de
notamment de marianne commander qui
avait alimenté nos réflexions
on l'avait d'autres on pourra dans le
débat peut être discutée sur d'autres
points qu'on a fait il y avait un
aliment merci madame
alors je faisais la parole peut-être en
premier à monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis puis ensuite monsieur
on dit merci monsieur le président merci
à monsieur pour votre présence vous vos
interventions et vos travaux sur le
l'adaptation aux changements climatiques
font partie des préoccupations de ma
commission au sénat aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
nous sommes mobilisés on essaie de
trouver des solutions pour pour être
efficace et considère aussi que les lois
inutiles affaiblissent les lois
nécessaires et qu'il faut parfois bien
soupeser mais vous avez fait un travail
approfondi par rapport aux auditions ce
qu'on fait actuellement
on voulait vous interroger sur l'âge est
un petit peu de de votre proposition
parce qu'on voit et vous l'avez rappelé
il ya on dit que cette phrase c'est une
phrase proposé par la convention
citoyenne
or il y avait déjà eu en 2018 en 2019
des propositions de phrases c'est
similaire à celle après les verbes ont
évolué et peut-être préciser comment
vraiment l'action précise de la
convention citoyenne ou est-ce que ça a
été soufflée par d'autres personnes et
deuxième question sur la halle à l'achat
de l'environnement et notamment
l'article 6
qui fait état de la mobilisation
nécessaire pour concilier la protection
et la mise en valeur de l'environnement
le développement économique et le
progrès social donc la définition du
développement durable doit posséder sur
la commission du développement durable
il ya ces trois notions à mettre sur le
même pied et pas de hiérarchisation à
avoir or le fait m dans l'article 1
pourrait créer cette hiérarchisation il
pourrait créer un
un contentieux et un certain nombre de
problèmes d'où nous un certain nombre
d'interrogations par rapport à la
proposition de révision de la
constitution
voilà ce que je peux dire à ce stade et
oui sur les effets juridiques que vous
attendez la portée
[Musique]
quel est quelle personne vous avez
auditionné dans au sein de votre
convention vous avez réfléchi entre vous
mais ce que vous avez auditionné donc la
vie des jurys de l'environnement des
constitutionnalistes et également le
monde économique
et quelle réflexion et quelles
interrogations
on veut on sera versée au sila les
convenants les conventions ta liste que
vous êtes
merci merci je vais la parole à quelques
autres collègues malhomme verrien
qu'être en visioconférence est ce
qu'elle nous entend et j'arrive tout de
suite merci beaucoup monsieur le
président alors ma question est vraiment
va continuer celle de monsieur
chevrollier puisque je vois pour de vrai
les gens qui ont participé à cette
convention à cette convention citoyenne
je découvre d'ailleurs que j'ai un
voisin de saint fargeau
je voulais savoir justement quelle était
la fare que vous aviez comment votre
réflexion c'était articulé entre
l'écologie et l'économie
et est ce que vous aviez rencontré
notamment je pense aux hauts normands et
aux bourguignons les syndicats agricoles
et les différents syndicats
d'entreprises par rapport à l'impact que
les différentes propositions que vous
faites pourraient avoir sur m6 c'est ma
b rien monsieur sueur si je me présente
le jean pierre sueur citoyen est aussi
sénateur
non je dis ça parce que vous voyez bien
pourquoi parce que nous sommes tous ses
citoyens et mais je tiens à vous dire
que j'ai été très intéressé par vos
propos que s'est sentie
que vous aviez il faut accepter le fruit
d'un travail où vous êtes vraiment
impliqué donc pour parler vrai comme mes
collègues finalement je vais vous poser
de se poser de questions la première jeu
je suis je ne suis pas persuadé mais de
la nécessité de remettre des phrases sur
le sujet alors qu'il ya la charte de
l'environnement et je n'ai pas pensé
qu'on pouvait peut-être modifier la
charte de l'environnement par exemple si
vous souhaitez insisté sur la réelle la
question du climat
parce que j'ai peur que ce soit fin un
peu redondant je dois dire que lorsqu'il
ya eu la charte dans l'environnement
s'était déjà sénateur voyez j'ai j'ai eu
beaucoup d'interrogations qui était lié
à notre ami robert badinter qui
trouvaient que le principe de précaution
n'était pas défini et c'est un vrai
sujet parce que quand on dit sion mais
qui garantit la préservation de
l'environnement bon mais une fois qu'on
l'a écrit et comme l'ont décrit principe
de précaution est aujourd'hui par
exemple il ya un vaccin dont on parle
tout le temps on en parle tellement que
les gens ne veulent certaines personnes
ne veulent plus faire vacciner alors je
dire j'applique le principe de
précaution 6 l'appliquent absolument
peut-être que je vais dire
tant pis je vais pas utiliser on va pas
utiliser ce faire que ça mais en même
temps si je ne le lui utilise pas je
vais faire que la maladie que le va
progresser que les risques vont
augmenter donc c'est pas en blanc ou
noir c'est à dire que à chaque fois ya
finalement une réflexion et de même par
rapport à votre idée toujours pour
l'inscription dans la constitution que
lorsqu'il y as conflit entre des valeurs
qui sont dans la constitution ce qui est
ce qui est un vrai sujet oui ça ne peut
pas porter atteinte à la préservation de
l'environnement
mais je dirais aussi pourquoi on ne
dirait pas si il y à conflit entre des
valeurs ça ne peut pas porter atteinte à
l'aspect social ou à la lutte contre la
grande pauvreté
est ce que je veux dire c'est à dire que
pour moi la préoccupation
environnementale est essentiel pendant
trop longtemps on là méconnu vous avez
parfaitement raison mais elle doit
toujours être articulé avec les
préoccupations liées à l'humanité tout
simplement parce que si l'homme
n'existait pas le mot environnement
n'existerait pas non plus c'est à dire
que on est ensemble finalement on en
fait partie
ça c'était la première série de
questions puis la deuxième pour de
battre mon président je voudrais
franchement qu'on parle d'un sujet vous
avez demandé qu' une nouvelle personne
ne tirés au sort dans le conseil
économique et social et environnemental
et nous ici puisqu'on effrangé pas on
est un certain nombre à avoir des
réticences
pourquoi et je peut-être je ne veux pas
vous
comment gérez vous que vous preniez mal
ce que je dis puisque fui francs c'est à
dire que nous bon moi j'ai été formé et
peut-être je suis un peu anciens jeux je
mets toutes les précautions dans l'idée
que le principe de la démocratie c'est
que des gens se présentent en disant
voilà vous votez pour moi mais je
défends un projet un programme et donc
les gens qui sont là ils sont par
rapport à dd s'en défendre des choses
pourquoi et on voit bien dans la
démocratie tout le monde ne défend pas
la même chose heureusement et j'avais un
peu peur pas je me demandais comment
justifier le caractère contingent un
petit peu hasardeuse du tirage au sort
au tirage au sort est un peu comme la
loterie qu'on peut gagner on peut le et
vous vous avez vécu ça et finalement
après six mois au moins où ils mois de
travail que vous avez menées
quelle est votre réflexion là dessus sur
en gros la démocratie classique celle
que nous représentons avec tous ses
défauts 1
et cet essor d'une sorte de démocratie
qui est le fruit du hasard mais le
hasard peut aussi avoir de bons effets
donc qu'est-ce qui vous fait penser que
ce serait mieux si au conseil économique
et social il y avait des gens de cire au
sort et je poserai même une question
pourquoi pas l'assemblée nationale au
sénat dans le même dans le même ordre
d'esprit ce que je veux dire
je me permets de poser cette question
peut-être que je suis un peu un délicat
m'enfin vous voyez je suis sincère et
que je vous dis ce que je pense
merci messieurs c'est un monsieur la
marque ensuite vers divorce à la je
voudrais remercier aussi les
participants qui sont venus 6 de la
convention citoyenne et jouer reprendre
en termes de jean pierre sueur qui a dit
que rennes était blanc rien était noir
je voudrais savoir d'abord si vous vous
êtes intéressé aussi à l'aménagement du
territoire
pourquoi
parce que certains effets de certaines
lois lorsqu'ils ne sont pas appliquées
aux territoires se révèle parfois
négatif depuis plus de 100 ans nous
constatons un exode rural
j'habite dans un département très rural
l'aveyron est ce que nous constatons
c'est que si la population augmente de
100 ou 200 habitants par an sur une
population de 280 mille habitants c'est
trop peu par contre les gens continuent
à s'agglutiner ans gilles de cela on a
déjà tenu compte il ya une dizaine
d'années lorsque l'on a prévu lescott et
caetera et on s'est dit la chose
suivante tous les dix ans il y a un
petit département français qui est
artificialisé non pas à cause de ces
départements ruraux qui sont souvent
entre la loi montagne quand ils ont des
grands lacs parfois même à la loi
littoral comme chez nous mais parce que
des départements ont fait n'importe quoi
et effectivement on a assisté à une
artificialisation des terres et à ce que
nous disions un département rural celle
que dix départements qui ce qu'on veut
c'est que dix ans serait artificialisés
aujourd'hui les conséquences de cela
avec une politique qui est national en
disant ceci alors qu'on a on a constaté
lors du confinement qu'il y avait un
retour des gens vers les zones rurales
nous sommes contraints par là au niveau
de l'urbanisme on en a tiré les
conséquences suivantes aussi dit que
d'un gp lui
regardez ce qui s'était passé dix ans
avant de projeter 10 ans acquise en
après midi on ne construira pas plus or
si on veut rééquilibrer le territoire à
sion 2 pas que les gens continuent la
suite du dîner en ville avec les
problèmes sociaux qui sont qui sont
conséquents les transports tous les
matins il conviendrait aller beaucoup
plus loin dans la nuance est d'aller de
faire de la dentelle et de se dire que
peut-être dans ces départements en
italie dans cet appartement là on
pourrait proposer plus de construction
de façon à avoir un nouveau des gens qui
habitent là qui ne se déplace pas qu'ils
restent autour de chez eux et qu'ils
n'ont pas toujours la nécessité
d'habiter en banlieue
et ce qui est contraire à ce que l'on
pourrait penser au niveau général donc
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin dans
l'analyse et permettre cela je dis cela
parce que nous sortons d'une campagne
électoral des sénatoriales
nous avons rencontré beaucoup de maires
des mères qui avaient des communes de
180 280 300 habitants qui sentent cette
volonté et qui sont aujourd'hui
par des lois sur l'urbanisme qui ont été
construites il ya dix quinze ans et qui
aujourd'hui s'applique et qui
malheureusement vont dans le sens
contraire de ce que nous souhaitons tous
au niveau de l'aménagement du territoire
bien évidemment que on peut toujours
prévoir des cuivres de rétention et ses
pouvoirs pour pour eux pour pas connu de
l'artificialisation même un milieu rural
mais allons vraiment dans la nuance
parce que c'est ça qui est important et
nous tirons pas ensuite des conséquences
juridiques au niveau national qui ne
serait pas celle que nous souhaitons
dalle pour le milieu rural et pour
l'aménagement du territoire j'ajoute que
la loi 4d va arriver et j'aimerais
savoir c'est justement les conséquences
juridiques que nous pourrions 2-2 du
texte qui sortira des assemblées n'ira
pas en contradiction avec la loi
4d et pour nous dans les départements
ruraux l'aménagement urbanistique est
absolument capital
merci monsieur marc même genre d'appui
en suivant gatel merci
je voulais savoir comment vous aviez été
désigné pour venir au sénat un stadier
avez vous été élu par vos pairs pour
venir représenter les 150 ou avez vous
été tiré au sort ou un autre mode de
désignation qui ne viendrait pas à
l'esprit aujourd'hui
deuxièmement j'ai une question à
monsieur costa je ne suis pas sûr
d'avoir bien compris ce que vous avez
dit tout à l'heure lorsque vous avez
parlé d' obligation de résultat sur le
réchauffement climatique
si c'est ce que j'ai compris auquel cas
je voulais savoir quel était pour vous
regarder évidemment de deux des
informations que vous avez pu avoir
quelle est la part anthropique dans le
réchauffement climatique et la troisième
question est pour eux madame blanche tôt
qui nous a expliqué que à son sens et au
regard évidemment des éléments qu'elle
avait eu aussi puisqu'elle n'est pas
prof de droit constitutionnel ni ni
effectivement professionnels du droit
constitutionnel
il pouvait y avoir une boîte de pandore
mais qu'elle ne serait pas ouverte pour
des raisons qu'elle nous a exposé je
dois d'être nous avons ici entendu trois
professeurs de droit constitutionnel
dont un conseiller d'état qui n'ont pas
eu la même opinion d'ailleurs ils
avaient tous les trois des opinions
différentes y compris sur le sens du mot
garantir ou du mot agir
ce qui signifie que les certitudes qu'on
peut avoir en réalité dont aucune
consistance
parce que nous ne savons absolument pas
ce que le conseil constitutionnel
pourrait dire les professionnels eux
mêmes ne le savent pas alors dans ces
conditions est il raisonnable d'ouvrir
une boîte de pandore qui consisterait
finalement lorsqu'on regarde le texte a
annulé toute activité humaine puisque
toute activité humaine y compris la
maison à laquelle nous vivons évidemment
est une atteinte à la nature et à la
biodiversité il il faut être il faut
être clair là dessus
donc voilà quels sont mes questions
merci madame bien telle fusion future
maman trois points je voudrais d'abord
vous remercier tous les trois de votre
présence ici aujourd'hui de votre
engagement et de vos travaux et comme
mon collègue et nous tous ici je suis
citoyenne sénatrice
que nous avons ce que certains appellent
une vraie vie et je suis élu local aussi
en ille et vilaine en bretagne où j'ai
longtemps été mais nous avons ici au
sénat mais je crois comme tout citoyen
conscience de la nécessité de préserver
ce qu'on appelle les ressources parce
que l'objectif est simple si de
transmettre à à nos successeurs amont
d'une planète que nous avons emprunté
mais où nous devons ville et que le
concept de développement durable qui a
été inventée est un concept
particulièrement intéressant parce qu'il
évoque trois piliers il évoque bien un
pilier environnemental
il évoque bien un pilier social et
sociétal et il évoque bien un pilier
économique et donc la loi doit être fait
et l'action aussi doit être fait pour
que ces trois piliers un septième ce que
l'un ne peut pas être cultivée au
détriment de l'autre deuxième point la
france est déjà engagée dans la
protection de l'environnement puisque la
charte de l'environnement est adossée à
la constitution ce qui n'est pas rien
dans notre pays et que des décisions de
justice ont déjà été prises notamment
sur la fabrication la vente la
transformation de médicaments dont la
production aurait nui aux ressources et
à la biodiversité donc on a déjà des
effets
troisième point c'est le mot que vous
défendez qui est le mot de garantie
alors moi je suis pas de
constitutionnalistes mais je lis le
français un peu comme chacun d'entre
nous et quand on regarde les synonymes
de garantir sa s'accomplit d'une
obligation de résultat
vous avez effectivement entendu j'ai
fait un travail considérable je n'en
n'ai eu aucun doute et je vous crois
avez-vous
vous faites des initiations de ce que
j'appelle des études d'impact
c'est à dire qu'elle est les faits et
les conséquences des mots que l'on
emploie et avez-vous auditionné dans
tous les travaux vous avez fait encore
une fois ils sont conséquents je ne nie
pas avez-vous auditionnés on a parlé des
acteurs économiques mais aussi des élus
et je vais vous prendre des aigles un
exemple très concret aujourd'hui pour
rebondir sur ce que disait notre
collègue marc il y a un objectif une
obligation de 0 artificialisation ça
veut dire en français tout simplement
qu'on ne peut pas aller prendre un
hectare de terres agricoles pour
construire des usines ou pour construire
des maisons et donc dans les communes ya
ce qu'on appelle des documents
d'urbanisme est amer dans ce document
d'urbanisme va lire pour répondre à
cette obligation
moi je gèle 30% de la surface de ma
commune qui ne seront pas constructif
pour garantir ce principe
or ne voilà-t-il pas que des citoyens il
n'en manque pas dans notre pays qui
confondent parfois l'intérêt privé
l'intérêt général
10 omer alerte vous avais-je les 30% de
terrain mais c'est 30% ne suffisent pas
pour atteindre l'obligation de garantie
c'est 70% de de terre et de surface de
votre commune que vous auriez dû que
vous auriez dû geler
autre exemple on imagine qu'il y a
nécessité de développer une petite ligne
ferroviaire pour désenclaver des
territoires dans le cantal où je ne
saisis donc des collectivités décide
d'un projet de liaison ferroviaire
absolument utile pour les habitants pour
les entreprises etc
l'association considère que
l'aménagement de cette ligne ferroviaire
a nui à la biodiversité
ne pensez-vous pas qu'une décision de
justice s'appuiera sur le mot garantir
et considérera que ces actions qui sont
faites pour servir le bien général et
désenclaver des territoires ne
considérais vous pas qu elle risque fort
d'être sanctionnés et qu'on va avoir un
blocage total est un peu fort de toute
action qui vise l'intérêt général jean
merci tient bien à elle même puis kerman
puis ensuite monsieur d'arnaud oui merci
a donc cécile cukierman de sénatrice de
la loire pour aller dans le même sens
peut-être que mes collègues tout d'abord
pour dire moi je joue à l'âge où je vous
remercie bien évidemment pour votre
présence ce matin je crois que vous vous
l'avez dit chacun avec vos mots
l'exercice n'est pas simple
il n'est pas simple même si nous sommes
tous citoyens d'entrer dans dans ce
temps de faire de choisir de décider et
de mettre en oeuvre ce que l'on pense ce
que l'on souhaite être long nous avons
en face à cette question climatique une
difficulté c'est que finalement dans ce
grand écosystème qui est celui de la
planète terre nous sommes le seul
élément à se soucier à la fois de notre
survie mais aussi de la survie de tous
les autres et de la planète qui nous
accueille si je dis cela c'est parce que
bien évident cette défense climatique
cette défense de l'environnement elle
est indissociable de l'aménagement du
territoire soit là et eddy de
l'aménagement du territoire dans lequel
vivent travail des femmes et les hommes
de notre pays de notre planète je
pourrais dire et pour reprendre ce que
disait même gatel ce qu'ont dit nos deux
collègues précédemment avec cette
volonté de garantir et vous l'avez très
bien rappelé bien on ne change pas la
constitution comme cela donc une fois
que c'est inscrit sept inscrits et cela
s'applique
dans tous les sens est ce qu'à un moment
donné vous avez pu mesurer toutes les
incidences et les conséquences que cela
veut dire
dans ce qui fait notre vie aujourd'hui
et parfois de la difficulté à trouver
des équilibres
j'ai envie de dire d'avoir dans vos
propres vies personnelles vous avez fait
tad de vos professions elles seront
inévitablement impacté dans cette dent
dans le fait vous êtes originaire de
deux départements de territoires
différents
ils seront inévitablement impactés
donc quoi sert qu'à un moment donné on a
cet objectif je crois de préserver même
pas 2 préserve de transmettre la planète
aux générations futures dans l'état le
moins dégradée qui soit pour que eux
puissent également y vivre demain mais
nous avons aussi la nécessité de
permettre et de faire vivre ensemble des
individus dans un territoire donné
l'exemple de la ligne des chemins de fer
du chemin de fer en est un mais
l'installation d'une entreprise
les produits utilisés par celle-ci des
événements rassemblant de très
nombreuses personnes pour des événements
quels qu'ils soient en sont et ils donc
il ya un moment donné ou comment est ce
que justement c'est cet enjeux
climatiques ne vient pas non plus
engendrer des difficultés dans la vie
des femmes et des hommes ne vient pas
non plus finalement limité et compris la
recherche et le progrès qui permet
inévitablement demain d'avoir des
activités humaines moins polluantes -
des règles qui dérègle rond le climat
qu'elles n'ont pu le faire par le passé
donc je crois en tout cas que c'est en
ceci que nous interrogeons sur une telle
inscription qui pourrait venir
finalement freiner le meilleur de ce que
l'activité humaine peut que te faire
pour demain en lien avec la préservation
du climat
un clic et en mains de monsieur d'arnaud
puis ensuite leur monsieur benarroch
après on laissera la parole à nos
invités
merci monsieur le président je ne vais
pas reprendre à mon compte même si je
les partage les propos qui viennent
d'être tenus par l'ensemble de mes
collègues ma question elle est très
simple et mon interrogation et est
relativement simple parce qu'on peut se
retrouver sur le sur le constat est sûre
le diagnostic que vous avez posé je
pense que il peut d'ailleurs faire large
largement consensus mon inquiétude est à
la marque l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
c'est qu'à l'heure où le législateur va
s'interroger dans quelques semaines sur
la nécessité qu'il y à différencier la
plupart de nos territoires parce qu'il
présente des spécificités tout à fait
singulière parce que les problématiques
rurales ne sont pas les problématiques
que l'on rencontre dans le tissu urbain
les problématiques du littoral ne sont
pas les problématiques que l'on retrouve
dans les territoires de montagne et si
on s'interroge sur cette nécessaire
différenciation
c'est parce que l'on a aussi opéré un
constat c'est qu'il est difficile
d'imposer à l'ensemble de nos
territoires
finalement des mesures qui seraient
j'allais dire largement uniforme et qui
s'appliquerait en tout lieu en tout
point de notre territoire de façon
justement uniforme et ça pour moi c'est
un écueil majeur qui contraint et
empêche toute forme d'agilité là où on a
bien vu et président tout à leur faisait
écho aux mouvements différents
mouvements sociaux notamment des dg les
jeunes mais pas que l'ensemble des
mouvements qui se sont levés au cours de
ces dernières années dans notre pays et
vous avez vous même et à juste titre
rappelé qu'il y avait lieu justement à
trouver ses points d'équilibré entre
l'activité économique et entre justement
tout ce qui fait aujourd'hui l'écologie
l'environnement et je crois qu'en cela
vous avez vous avez parfaitement raison
mais ma crainte c'est qu'en élevant
certaines de vos propositions rang
constitutionnel singulièrement en
inscrivant l'article 1 ne va pas ton
plutôt contraindre encore un peu plus et
demander à ce que soit appliquée de
façon très uniforme voit pas voir
parfois un peu rigide certaines
dispositions à l'ensemble pour rester
sur le champ des territoires à
l'ensemble de nos territoires là où on
aurait plutôt besoin un peu d'agilité en
ce sens et je le dis très directement je
me retrouvais bien dans la proposition
formulée par notre collègue questeur
cuir sur la charte de l'environnement
qui comme l'a rappelé françoise gatel
est adossé à la
constitution parce que justement pour
moi elle permettait ce besoin de
différenciation et d'agilité voilà donc
on se retrouve effectivement sur les
constats mais ma préoccupation
s'agissant de l'inscription dans la
constitution c'est véritablement celle
ci merci monsieur arnaud et enfin
monsieur benarroch quête en visio oui
merci
le président d'angus libye benarroch et
je suis des bouches du rhône me il était
à midi et donc en fait je suis
essentiellement là pour écouter les
jeunes la convention citoyenne que je
sais j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
pour certains d'entre eux puisque je
veux dire tous mes collègues bien
introduits il est possible de rencontrer
des gens de la convention citoyenne très
facilement
là où nous nous trouvons dans les
régions nous sommes ou ailleurs
physiquement ou aux visions et donc je
l'occasion déjà de m'entretenir avec
nombre d'autres plusieurs fois je ne
vais pas entamer le débat avec mes
collègues parce que sinon nous
parlerions tout le temps et nous ne
laisserions pas la parole mais je ne
partage pas la plupart des choses que tu
ai dit effectivement il est temps de
passer sur un autre rythme et au niveau
législatif et au niveau constitutionnel
et au niveau des actions à mener
tous les moyens peuvent être étudiées
pour y arriver une transition un
changement réel du mode de société de
production de consommation dans lequel
nous trouvons est aujourd'hui nécessaire
nous ne sommes pas dans la situation
nous trouvions au moment de la
promulgation de la charte de
l'environnement
vous savez tous à quel point la
situation de notre planète la situation
de la biodiversité la situation liée au
changement climatique rend de jour en
jour 7
ce combat et cette lutte plus urgents et
à quel point nous ne devons pas
aujourd'hui nous contenter d'un certain
nombre d'éléments de mesures ou 2 ou 2
août d'actes législatifs qui n'ont pas
pour l'instant permis effectivement de
prendre à bras le corps ce problème
je n'irai pas plus loin dans ce débat
puisque on aura l'occasion d'en parler
bien entendu je vais deux questions qu'a
posées
après avoir remercié aux trois personnes
qui sont venues là
première et en dehors de ce projet de
loi constitutionnelle aussi vous utile
de faire figurer dans la loi
le terme est là nous sur deco side et la
deuxième question c'est quel comment
comptez vous faire pour venir permettre
aux députés aux sénateurs qu'ils
étudient ou qui vont étudier au dehors
de ce pays elle s'est ensuite la loi
climat et résilience pour pouvoir leur
permettre d'adapter et d'adopter une
grande partie des mesures que vous aviez
préconisé lors de la convention
citoyenne
merci merci monsieur benarroch voilà
vous avez neuf interventions qui se sont
succédé autant de questions à la fois
juridique et est traitée est très
théorique mais importante que de
questions pratiques
donc je sais pas dans quel ordre si vous
aviez commencé monsieur monsieur costa
ou monsieur pratte ouais je vais
commencer ça ne dérange pas très bien
comment juste après merci beaucoup de
toutes vos questions
davance désolé parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de questions il est
possible qu'on en échappe une ou deux ne
pensez pas que c'est parce qu'on veut
pas y répondre
n'hésitez pas à revenir vers nous dans
un second temps même après pour qu'on y
réponde parce que je trouve ça très
important qu'on répondra à toutes vos
questions qui sont toutes très
rapidement je l'étais commencé voix sur
les questions qui sont pas rares article
1er notamment ben j'ai commencé sur la
question sur le tirage au sort par
exemple sur la question de la légitimité
de ces citoyens qui en fait on qu'on est
allé chercher et je vous l'avais rappelé
monsieur le président nous et nous
avions un rôle consultatif déjà nous
avions pas un rôle décisionnel et nous
cherchons pas à la voir
nous sommes là encore construction avec
des représentants élus et il est
important de le rappeler
effectivement on a préconisé que
au conseil économique social et
environnemental il puisse y avoir des
citoyens tirés au sort parce que pour
l'avoir expérimenté on pense à 150 que
le tirage au sort est une belle est un
bon mode de démocratie participative
voir délibératif ça permet en fait aux
citoyens qui ne s'impliquent pas qu'ils
ne veulent pas s'impliquer ou qui n'ont
pas le temps de s'impliquer bas de
participer à la vie de la cité et ça
c'est quelque chose de quelque chose de
positif parce que oui on va chercher des
gens très grande précarité des gens qui
sont pas forcément diplômés des mères au
foyer c'est des gens qui vont pas
forcément se présenter à des élections
ou être militant 1 un parti politique
donc effectivement moi je crois en la
démocratie représentative je crois nous
représentants élus mais je crois aussi
qu'on peut leur leur adjoindre des
citoyens qui seront là pour leur faire
des propositions pour les conseiller
pour apporter autre chose pour être un
peu la cerise sur la gâteau
institutionnels donc moi je pense que
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre et je trouve
ça au contraire ça qu'on puisse adjointe
du citoyen un peu partout ensuite je
vais aller sur les questions
d'aménagement du territoire parce qu'en
plus vous avez de la chance avec mon
collègue costa nous étions dans le
groupe seloger donc nous avons parlé de
ces problématiques notamment d'
artificialisation des sols
on a fait plusieurs propositions pour
cette artificialisation des sols et oui
effectivement nous avons pris en nous
avons pris un ouais je trouve pas mon
terme mais ces parages en utiliser un
autre merci beaucoup nous avons pris en
compte tous les acteurs locaux nous
avons rencontré nous avons même certains
de nos citoyens qui sont maires de très
petites communes
donc oui nous avons pris en compte tout
cela et nous avons mis en oeuvre des
propositions qui vise à tendre vers le
zéro artificialisation déjà avec une
temporalité bien défini et aussi avec
des logiques de compensation par exemple
et des logiques qui seront nous on avait
l'échelle du scot je crois que ton
l'anac dans la loi que la résilience ce
sera à l'échelle du str adepte
c'est la position qu'il avait adoptée
gouvernement mais ce qui est important
pour nous c'est le schéma de cohérence
parce qu'effectivement des communes qui
ont artificialisés tous leurs chants moi
je suis dans une petite commune normande
may a pris aucun champ donc forcément la
question d'artificialisation ne se pose
pas la même que pour d'autres communes
ou
il ya des choses qui ce qui reste à
faire donc ce qui est important c'est le
schéma de cohérence est l'élément
central est effectivement on ne veut pas
freiner toute artificialisation veut pas
freiner tout développement
l'idée c'est de le faire en cohérence
avec nos territoires avec les besoins
mais aussi avec le besoin de
préservation parce que le besoin de
préservation de la biodiversité c'est
pas un besoin accessoires c'est pas un
besoin béquille c'est un besoin qui est
aussi central et c'est un peu l'objet de
2 mètres aussi dans les valeurs de la
république dans cet article la notion de
biodiversité d'environnement et de
contrôle de développement climatique
c'est de les mettre en fait au même
niveau et c'est de dire que ça aussi ça
doit être pris en compte et ça c'est
important c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas suffisamment pris
en compte je continue sur pièce qu'on
est auditionné en fait écrit et seront
ses adjoints pour faire ses propositions
bah oui on a auditionné des acteurs
économiques des élus vous pourrez
retrouver sur le site de la convention
citoyenne de très rapidement accessibles
sur google vous verrez en fait si on a
rencontré nous allons rencontrer 200 à
250 intervenants et nous avons rencontré
bawin des élus ou des acteurs des clown
ou couillon des acteurs français à nos
propositions
on les a vus une première fois pour la
construction et on vous a vu une seconde
fois pour la confrontation à nos idées
pour qu'ils puissent nous faire des
retours justement pour qu'on puisse
faire des mesures d'étude d'impact nous
avions des gens qui étaient là pour nous
accompagner parce que les 156 points
avec l'autre ibra effectivement tout
seul nous n'aurions pas eu les moyens
mais nous avions eu la chance d'avoir
les moyens du cod moyens de l'état et
les moyens de tous ces intervenants
d'ailleurs avec des avis parfois très
divergents qui nous ont aidés à
construire cette proposition et c'est
justement ce consensus lac nous on
allait chercher et je le rappelle aussi
à des 150 citoyens nous mêmes nous
avions des 10 ans us entre nous nous
avions le cri des jo ligne à la personne
qui était en très très grande précarité
voire qui dormaient dans la rue et c'est
ce consensus klein qui a amené ses
propositions à être mise sur la table
et oui on a pris en compte tous les tous
les champs tous les acteurs autant que
possible bien sûr mais comme vous le
faites également en en commission je
vais finir sur ce point vendre et c'est
ma parole à mes concitoyens
c'est sur cette notion de qui m'a fait
plaisir c'est que effectivement vous
sénateur vous êtes citoyen mais
effectivement et ça personne ne le nie
et nous d'ailleurs ce qu'on propose pour
cet article lu ans et de le mettre au
référendum
c'est
dire en fait on va demander à tous les
citoyens nous les 150 citoyens vous les
sénateurs citoyens mais aussi les
citoyens non élu et ce qu'on demande là
au sénat est ce qu'on a demandé à
l'assemblée nationale ce n'est pas de
changer la constitution
c'est de faire cette proposition d'art
français pour coller français dernier
juge de loi puisse décider si oui ou non
il doit les y aller donc effectivement
ce travail préalable est très important
parce que il faut pas que des
propositions farfelues tombe bien sûr et
qu'on fasse des référendum tous les
quatre matins mais là la proposition
qu'on souhaite faire par référendum
c'est de demander bah oui à ces 40
millions 45 millions d'électeurs est ce
que vous vous pensez que cette
hiérarchie entre les valeurs est-ce que
vous pensez que cette direction vers la
préservation vers la garantit la
préservation de la biodiversité de
l'environnement la lutte contre le
développement climatique est ce que vous
voulez y aller et là en fait on pourra
demander aux français de se poser la
question
donc déjà on aura un temps d'éducation
de sensibilisation de formation à la
question climatique qui sera très
important parce que le constat
effectivement non le partage mais
beaucoup de gens encore malheureusement
ne le partage pas ça permettra ce temps
d'appropriation collectif et ça
permettra aux français
ben voilà deux de se donner une
direction de se donner
ben voilà un choix et ce choix là pour
nous c'est important que les français
puissent le passé la main la question
pour eux puisqu'en des seules questions
dites périphériques la question d'âme
jorda sait comment tous les trois vous
êtes venus
quand vous aider les farc ont été
choisis pour venir se maintient je
répondre très rapidement en fait à
l'issue de la convention citoyenne après
ses huit mois de travaux nous avons
constitué une association qui s'appelle
les 150 cette association donc nous
sommes aujourd'hui je crois entre 120 et
130 citoyens sur ces 150 preuve que le
citoyen engagé quand on est allé le
chercher par tirage au sort il continue
encore à prêt à s'engager et nous
faisons partie nous d'un petit groupe
parce qu'en fait nous avons douze
groupes thématiques au sein de cette
association éducation déplacement
habitat nous faut nous nous faisons
partie nous du groupe constitution
victoire et moi en sommes les animateurs
et donc nous avons fonctionné par
consensus pour savoir qui était le plus
apte à répondre à vos questions
c'est pour ça que nous sommes présents
aujourd'hui devant vous non j'en ai été
le co président mais aujourd'hui je suis
un simple citoyen cette fois ces
associations au même titre que mes deux
autres collègues
moi j'ai pas pris de notes mais je pense
que toute façon c'est ça va être plus de
mon côté mon ma sensibilité c'est plus
générale le dérèglement climatique et la
biodiversité en fait c'est est ce qu'on
l'intègre ou pas moi je n'arrête pas de
me battre sur les réseaux sociaux avec
des gens qui a qui croient pas ou qui
veulent pas y croire je pense que là on
est à un tournant ou ou vraiment un
faucon faut qu'on fasse des choix
voilà des choix de société pas
spécialement sur l'environnement mais
sur notre rapport à l'autre au niveau
géopolitique aussi hein parce que bon là
les politiques on voit ce qui est dit ce
qui est fait et les gens il commença à
se détourner pour venir vers des trucs
un peu plus à la recentrer les gens
qu'ils y croient quoi parce que même
nous on n'a été lésé
moi j'ai pas honte de le dire on a on a
déposé des textes et il devait pas y
avoir de filtres enfin voilà savez
comment ça s'est passé
donc c'est tout ça qui fait que les gens
n'y croient plus moi dès le début de la
convention autour de moi on m'a dit mais
pourquoi tu te casse la tête à faire ça
de toute façon à la fin c'est tout va
être démontée et j'ai dit non
j'ai dix pourquoi ça va être démontée je
vais faire le processus j'y crois j'ai
cru pour aussi le président pas de
filtre bond a été filtré et on peut pas
continuer comme ça les politiques ne
peuvent pas continuer les gens ne
peuvent pas continuer à nier qu'on a des
problèmes
les deux degrés c'est fini vous prenez
jancovici il le dit clairement
les deux degrés on les sait morts donc
voilà après pour répondre à un madame
oui il faut il faut qu' il faut qu'on
continue à vivre
normal il faut qu'on continue à
développer des développé tout un tas de
choses qui seront utiles pour nous mais
il faut prendre ça en compte et qu'on ne
pourra pas continuer à vivre comme on a
fait jusqu'à présent
sans prendre en compte tous les tous les
enjeux qui a on le sait tout le monde le
sait on peut se voiler la face
mais tous les jours sa tombe les
glaciers que ça soit les glaciers que ça
soit les problèmes de dos ça soit les
espèces qui disparaissent alors voilà
nous on n'est pas bon le monde nous
appartient pas on fait partie du monde
on a les mêmes at home qu' aucune plante
qu'une pierre qu'un arbre voilà donc
soit on choisit de faire un monde où on
va s'adapter
on va s'adapter et on va faire en sorte
que tout ce qu'on produit va aller dans
le bon sens ce qui répond un peu à votre
question aussi l'artificialisation des
sols on peut on peut continuer à
construire seulement là on construit
avec des matériaux qui sont pas
renouvelables
donc bien sûr qu'on peut continuer à
construire ce dès l'instant qu'on change
et qu'on va vers du renouvelable la
maison on la construit il jouait les
démos liés à la panne impact ce qui est
pas le cas on sait que le ciment c'est
hyper émetteurs de co2 donc c'est tout
ça qu'il faut prendre en compte et soit
vous l'intégrer vous vous dites ok on va
tout faire progressivement
il n'ya pas progressivement mais assez
vite quand même parce qu'on n'a pas trop
de temps quand même et on va dans ce
sens là où soit on continue comme ont
fait jusqu'à présent
et puis on continue la vie comme on l'a
maintenant avec le commerce condat
maintenant avec les échanges qu'on fait
et puis on verra bien à quel moment au
suicide parce que le sait ce qui va
arriver
moi mon frère il me dit moi je m'en
fiche dans tant d'années je serai plus
là ouais ok on peut voir les choses
comme ça tous les jours je me bats avec
lui mais moi je vois pas les choses
comme ça j'ai des enfants et après après
mes enfants ça serait bien qu'ils aient
des enfants que ça continue on peut pas
se dire allez on s'éclate pendant
pendant encore 20 ou 30 ans et puis
après on verra bien ce qui arrive
donc voilà c'est ce que je voulais dire
merci monsieur costa jeu tout peut-être
non non ils vont réaliser les elysées
nous n'avons pas fin à ce point tort on
n'était pas là pour pardon on était en
tant que citoyens tirés au sort on
n'était pas là pour écrire les lois ça
c'est votre votre travail et c'est déjà
pour nous ça ne s'arrêtait énorme donc
non on vous laisse ça mais on était là
pour dire que ce que nous en tant que
citoyen qu'est ce qui nous paraît
acceptable par la société et honnêtement
on a eu on a auditionné plein de
personnes on n'a pas accepté on n'a pas
pris tout ce qu'ils nous ont dit on a
jugé par afin par exemple la démographie
bas ça nous paraissait pas acceptable de
légiférer là dessus
voilà deux donc par exemple le taxer la
viande ça nous a pas paru acceptable
j'ai tant le temps groupe se nourrir on
n'a pas tous pris comme ça il ya autre
chose
enfin moi ce que j'ai appris c'est du
coup par rapport à ça c'est l
intelligence collective de citoyens qui
venaient de tous horizons
comment ils vivaient qu'est-ce que ça
impacte est justement dans leur vie et
c'est tout ça qu'on a pris en compte et
ce que j'ai appris aussi dans cette
convention alors moi faut savoir que
j'avais pas conscience de l'urgence
climatique et comme beaucoup de mes
concitoyens donc on a vraiment pris une
claque
ce que j'ai appris c'est que en fait la
transition écologique et la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique c'est une
opportunité aussi cesser c'est faut pas
que ce soit vu comme quelque chose qui
va tout bloquer et tous paralysés
c'est une opportunité à saisir les six
aujourd'hui la france ne fait pas
d'autres pays le front et puis quelques
arguments quand on dit oui ça bloquerait
par exemple les innovations ça bloquera
peut-être les innovations qui sont
néfastes mais ça bloquera pas les
innovations pour lesquelles on a
réfléchi aux conséquences
ensuite ce qu'on veut c'est justement
développer des industries d'avenir et
protéger nos entreprises pour qu'elles
soient plus résiliente et tout ça c'est
c'est pas quelque chose qui doit qui
doit être vu comme quelque chose qui
paralyse notre économie ensuite on avait
enfin tout ce que vous nous dites
honnêtement on ya pensé moi la première
je me disais mais est-ce qu'il faut
changer la constitution et piqué sont
les risques
on nous on a parlé aussi de 1 mais si
vous faites ça les entreprises ont tout
se délocaliser mais on ne voit là on en
a beaucoup discuté puis avec les
intervenants ces terrains on s'est
beaucoup renseigné parce qu'il y avait
le travail pendant les sessions mais
aussi les travaux en dehors des sessions
et aujourd'hui les industries du futur
qu'est ce que c'est
les plus gros développement qui va ya
voir ça avec les entreprises qui sont
respectueuses de l'environnement
donc les autres je vais dire au bout
d'un moment que ce soit parce que les
consommateurs changent ou parce que
voilà tout ce qui est rse dans les
entreprises et cetera ça n'ira pas dans
un autre sens donc et puis quand il faut
c'est justement en protégeant nos terres
et nos sols et enzo qu'on assure la
survie de nos industries y compris
l'agriculture
on parlait tout à l'heure des
intervenants danger tant groupe se
nourrir on a eu des débats
contradictoires avec pour vous ou d'un
exemple greenpeace la fnsea et le
directeur de système u voilà donc vous
voyez un peu c'était il y avait de
l'ambiance mais c'était hyper fin
c'est vraiment ces débats là qui ont
alimenté notre réflexion et oui on a vu
avec le spectre de l'économie il y avait
des gens qui sont touchés
enfin dans l'instant et des gens qui
travaillent dans les secteurs qu'on a
évoqué l'aviation et c'est donc bien
entendu on a pris en compte l'économie
on n'a pas voulu mettre l'écologie au
dessus de tout il faut concilier tout ça
et d'ailleurs les les
les libertés demeure égal en fait le
juge et devra les concilier il devra pas
m enfin ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure le juge il devra concilier tout
ça en fait c'est pas une histoire de
mettre quelque chose en dessus de
l'autre et puis par contre si on fait
rien laquelle la france est la france
s'expose à des condamnations dans
quelques années par l'europe ou par
voilà de dot dans le monde on s'expose à
d'autres choses donc il faut absolument
prendre en compte 16 ans est en jeu et
sur le thème garantir et bien il existe
déjà dans la constitution par exemple il
est écrit que la république garantit à
tous la protection de la santé la
sécurité matérielle le repos et le
loisir donc voilà le terme garantir gsa
qu avec le recul j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre pourquoi il ya un tel blocage
là dessus des îles et figure à plusieurs
dans des reconstitutions et puis
par rapport à la liberté d'entreprendre
la liberté d'entreprendre
c'est pas enfin la liberté c'est faire
ce qui ne nuit pas à autrui à autrui la
liberté d'entreprendre sa jamais été de
polluer et de porter atteinte à
l'environnement
donc voilà le juste c'est tout ça qui
est qui conciliera et çà voudra pas dire
que on arrêtera toute industrie et qu'on
fera plus rien qu'on frappe les deux
routes et qu'on fera plus de c'est c'est
du bon sens et c'est un message fort
pour notre démocratie
l'ennemi c'est le droit de rêver quand
même à lamu je dis ça à peine en
plaisantant parce que je j'entends ce
que vous dites et je partage ma petite
personne d'une grande partie du film de
tout ce que vous dites et j'entends
quand vous exprimer l'idée sur laquelle
les enjeux environnementaux ne doivent
pas non plus et des enjeux bloquant en
termes de développement et ça c'est très
sensible naturellement la question or
avant qu'on lève notre notre séance
la question de la clarification parce
qu'on va s'y plus une clarification
qu'autre chose je vois pas d'opposition
en réalité sur les enjeux et que vous
posez tous les trois je suis intimement
convaincu que tous ceux qui sont ici les
partages il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
mais notre rôle est un rôle de
législateur donc il faut bien qu'on
fasse un peu de droit et lorsque vous
dites que tout ce délai ce qui dans la
constitution et d'égal valeur vous avez
raison c'est ce que dit la constitution
mais tout à l'heure vous vous disiez que
le terme garantis avait j'ai cru
comprendre pour vous une obligation de
résultat or lorsque vous évoquez à
l'instant
les termes de garantie qui a utilisé par
ailleurs dans la constitution vous avez
raison de cela il est conçu ou imaginé
comme une obligation de moyens dont
toute la question qui se pose notre
débat c'est comment dans son
interprétation lorsqu'il le rap un
moment l'obligation de se prononcer le
constituent le conseil contenait des
constats des juges du conseil
constitutionnel vont interpréter la
notion de garantir car en réalité
aujourd'hui
si on regarde la jurisprudence constante
du conseil constitutionnel il n'y a pas
d'obligation de moyens dirigeants de
résultats cercle ya pas une vision
civilistes des choses c'est une autre
vision et tout sujet il est là en fait
une ambiguïté là je joue mes freins
théorie je me permets de drainage et ont
des choses en main je suis assez
d'accord avec vous il vous inquiétez pas
on va bien jours d'essais réveillon on
peut et on peut rêver on peut rêver de
voler dans des avions qui sont verts je
crois qu airbus et safran trahissant le
sujet et nous on pousse à les aider dans
leur investissement fait partie aussi
des mesures de la convention citoyenne
je tenais à le préciser
non mais c'est important sur ces notions
juridiques nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord avec vous et ça fait partie des
débats qu'on a eue sur ce choix des
terrains parce que effectivement nous on
a beaucoup hésité pour être tout à fait
honnête moi j'étais plus partisan au
départ d'un terme comme agir par exemple
qui était peut-être moins malléable
juridiquement mais on a fait ce choix
collectifs parce que ce temps garantir à
mener selon nous une obligation henin
est quasi obligation de résultat pour
reprendre les termes du conseil d'état
[Musique]